foreign
[Music]
welcome everyone as I said I mentioned a
moment ago my name is Alfred guy and I
work in the porter Center as the
Director of undergraduate tutoring I
also oversee the writing requirement in
Yale College and I teach courses in
English and Humanities I'm going to give
about a two-minute introduction to this
panel and then we're going to get right
to the faculty speakers
uh within a week of chat GPT 3.5 being
released on November 30th the portrait
Center started to get questions from
faculty about its implications for
teaching
because this technology is potentially
so disruptive which I don't mean as
pejorative
um for teaching and learning we all have
questions and so it made sense to gather
people to talk we're very grateful to
The Faculty panel for agreeing to launch
this conversation which we expect will
also continue well after this event
the format for the event is that each
faculty panelist will speak for five
minutes about their ideas for how AI
generative writing might affect teaching
and learning
after the panelists we will have time to
hear some questions that were submitted
in advance and some questions that
people generate during this meeting via
chat we may get more questions than we
can use today but we will use them to
shape future programming and resources
that we build about these issues I want
to welcome nishit vishnoy from the
computer science department Professor
vishnoy is the a Bartlett Giamatti
professor of computer science and a
co-founder of the computation and
Society initiative at Yale University
he studies the foundations of
computation and his research spans
several areas of theoretical computer
science optimization and machine
learning
he's also interested in understanding
nature and Society from a computational
viewpoint
here his current Focus includes studying
the emergency of intelligence excuse me
it is that's a Freudian slip studying
the emergence of intelligent behavior
and ethical problems at the interface of
artificial intelligence and Society
Professor vishnoy welcome
thank you Alfie
um yes I guess it was a 40 slip I mean
we are in some kind of an emergency uh I
guess and I'm very glad to see uh so
many people interested in this event so
um I'll keep my remarks brief and to the
point uh I guess we are all here to uh
talk about chat GPT which is one of the
latest in the line of what is what are
called generative models in AI so these
are algorithms which can learn
about
things such as images or in this case uh
you know texts and are able to do
conversations with human beings and I
guess what has caught our attention here
is the ability to have these kinds of
very non-trivial interactions with human
beings and that's caused a lot of
concern so from my point of view I think
coming to the point of how it impacts
the teaching and learning
I think the first point I would like to
say is that it uh
um it it will add to showing us the gap
between learning and evaluation
I mean as I guess
um as a university our goal is to ensure
that our students learn but how we check
whether they have learned these three
evaluations and I guess the concern that
arises is how students are going to use
this tool or tools such as this which
are likely to come in future to to Aid
in their evaluation so my my prognosis
is that in the short term I would
imagine that this Gap will increase
uh but I think it does give us a very uh
nice opportunity to think about how we
can reduce the misalignment between
learning and evaluation
the second point I would make is about
how it can impact
um
um the power and biases already present
in society even we don't have to take
the example of chat GPD but even
previous uh tools from natural language
processing and computer vision have
Illustrated that uh these these
algorithms can propagate certain types
of biases enabling or increasing the
power of certain groups in society
and I I believe these kinds of two like
chat GPT will work both ways on the one
hand they will level the playing field
for example if you have let's say if
English is not your natural language and
you would like to compose a nice email
to your professor or to whoever then you
can put in a partially phrased email or
not an appropriate not necessarily the
finished email and get a polished
version of it and you can imagine these
kinds of uses which will reduce the gap
between different groups who for
whatever reason have to spend more
resources coming up with the same
outcome
uh on the other hand given that these
are generated models which are learning
from existing data which data doesn't
come from vacuum it comes from the
society that we live in it will for sure
propagate the power the the bias uh uh
that already exists and I think things
have to be done to check these kinds of
biases
I guess one of the things uh um
um that might be also of concern is
immediate concern is that if students
start using chart GPD how are we going
to
check and enforce whether there is some
kind of cheating in some way or the
other this probably applies to uh exams
which are more which are a more written
component into it and I I believe that
uh that's that's something that uh chat
GPT itself is or open AI itself is
thinking about how to include
watermarking which is a technique from
computer science which allows you to
spot if certain answers or
um
you know I have been generated using
this uh
software or this algorithm
yeah so I think these are the key points
and I will pass it on to the others and
I'm curious to hear about my other
colleagues and and audiences have to say
thank you
that's wonderful thank you so much
professor vishnoy
um so our second panelist is going to be
Brian scasolati also from the computer
science department Professor scasolati
is the a Bartlett Giamatti professor of
computer science cognitive science and
mechanical engineering
he built robots that help people by
providing social and cognitive support
including systems that teach social
skills to children with autism systems
that help adults cope with anxiety and
depression and systems that tutor
children in challenging subjects
his work not only produces useful tools
but also helps us to learn about the
ways in which people understand social
behavior categorize things as animate
and inanimate and collaborate with each
other
so thank you and welcome professors
casalotti
thanks very much Alfie and uh thanks
nishit for giving us a really good start
and foundation for this
um I guess my first message was really
inspired by a lot of the the teachers
and Educators that I spoke to recently
and it's simply this don't panic we've
been here before
um in 1966 uh Joe weisenbaum wrote this
program called Eliza that at the time
was thought of as this incredible new
thing but even weisenbaum admitted it
was a very very simple program all it
did was take in a line of text and look
for certain patterns and replace one set
of words with another so if you said to
Eliza I'm really worried about my father
it would pick out the word worried and
my father and it would write back and
say why are you worried about your
father
and it followed this school of thought
that's uh now identified as rogerian
Psychotherapy where the idea was to
mirror back without adding anything to
the conversation
and at the time many people thought of
this as almost a solution to natural
language
people were worried that this was going
to replace them in their jobs the
association for Psychotherapy wrote
weisenbaum and begged him to get rid of
the program
weisenbaum's own assistant he had to
fire because she did nothing other than
talk to Eliza all day even serious
natural language researchers this brand
new field that had just begun
some of them were wrote that probably
they were only a few years away from
solving language whatever that meant
we've seen this before and there's
always a lot of hype and excitement that
comes when new technologies come out
now that's not to say that Chachi PT
isn't an amazing piece of technology
but we've faced these problems before
in 2015 I taught the first version of
cs50 here at Yale
and we had almost 425 students in the
class it was I think it is still the
largest engineering course we've ever
taught here
and when we did we realized that between
400 students here and 800 students at
Harvard we were going to have problems
with academic honesty
and along the way we developed some
tools and we used some existing tools
out there to help us because there were
already at the time huge databases of
code and and even completed assignments
that were available online not to
mention forums like stack exchange where
you could pose a question and someone
would hopefully give you a piece of code
as an answer
or even automated systems like co-pilot
that would write code along with you
so how could we distinguish these
automatically generated or just plain
plagiarized pieces from everything else
now for us at the time one of the key
things was we looked at the white space
that is the the difference between
spaces and tabs and line fields in that
code that was written
and in fact it was very easy to find the
students who had copied things directly
because those patterns were very obvious
and very easy to spot
that's not going to be the same with
chat GPT
it's not going to be as easy for us just
to say and go in and look and say are
there the right number of spaces in
between that period and the start of the
next line
but there are patterns
I think overall the second message I
would want to bring today is just to say
in a way this is a challenge it is a
challenge for us as educators
but I think it's actually a very good
challenge because it's forcing us to
look for creative and original thought
and not just what these systems do which
is just a rewording and a regurgitation
of the sources that they have been fed
I think that in the whole this will make
us a stronger and better
organization a way in which we can train
our students to be more robust thinkers
but it will be more effort along the way
so there is a challenge out there for us
right now
how do we look at the way that we take
these written submissions and evaluate
them not just based on how they can
replay sources from us
but rather look for that creative and
original thought
thanks very much
thank you so much that that was
wonderful thank you
um
all right so I'm going to introduce
Laura Wexler our next speaker Laura
Professor Wexler is the Charles H
Farnham professor of American studies
and women's gender and sexuality studies
the acting co-chair of the Yale public
Humanities program and a founding member
of femtechnet the feminist technology
Network
a scholar of Photography and visual
culture she is the founding Pi principal
investigator of photo grammar an
interactive multi-layered geospatial map
of the more than 170 000 photographs and
metadata taken and collected by the farm
Security Administration between 1935 and
1944 and housed at the Library of
Congress
she is interested in all aspects of the
digital learning space so thank you and
welcome Professor Wexler oh thank you
very much I I'm so pleased that this is
happening and thank you Alfie and Jenny
Frederick and the poorvu center for
allowing us to have this opportunity for
opening this discussion together as a
community and I thank my two colleagues
whose remarks were very much I think on
point and really helpful
um it does seem to me also that we've
been here before cell phones and
computers Wikipedia Google search spell
check just in the last few years in the
academy there have been a lot of changes
that have been said to Herald the end of
things as we know them and that that we
had to put up defensive barriers in our
classrooms against them
but somehow I have a contrarian feeling
that leads me all the way back to a very
ancient story that I want to share with
you today
okay so this is just pieces of this
story a long time ago a famous teacher
told this story to one of his pupils he
was talking about an Egyptian God who
had invented writing and was trying to
tell the King of Thieves about how he
invented writing
and he said it will make Egyptians wiser
and will improve their memory I have
discovered a potion for memory and for
wisdom
and the King replied oh most expert Cod
one man can give birth to the elements
of an art but only another can judge how
they can benefit or harm those who will
use them and now since you are the
father of writing your affection for it
has made you describe its effects as the
opposite of what they really are in fact
writing will introduce forgetfulness
into the soul of those who learn it they
will not practice using their memory
because they will put their trust in
writing which is external and depends on
signs that belong to others instead of
trying to remember from the inside
completely on their own you have not
discovered a potion for remembering but
for reminding
you provide your students with the
appearance of wisdom not with its
reality
your invention will enable them to hear
many things without being properly
taught and they will imagine that they
have come to know much while for the
most part they will know nothing and
they will be difficult to get along with
since they will merely appear to be wise
instead of really being so
this is of course Socrates and this is
the fedress that dialogue that Plato
wrote down because Socrates wouldn't use
writing to write his own teachings down
your students will not learn from the
inside and they will be hard to get
along with because they will imagine
that they know something when actually
they know nothing
and what this is I think at base
underneath the sensationalism of all the
headlines is the college essay over is
the college class over is a college
education over our College instructors
over is this over which you know sells
papers that's why we're being asked
these questions at base this is a very
much the same fear if you if you commit
learning to writing
students will not know from the inside
but what I want to focus on about this
very interesting ancient dialogue is
that Socrates is a solution does not lie
in a clever assignment or a brilliant
prompt or a way of keeping the
collaborative AI out of the space of the
classroom it actually relies on Person
to Person presence between people
learning together teachers and students
so that the writing is merely a reminder
of the embodied real I thou another
philosopher would have said knowledge
that's being communicated in the
classroom and to me I would like to
focus on this aspect of the The
Challenge and the opportunity that is
before us because it's very exciting
what the AI can now do and very exciting
to learn not it's not that we're being
confronted with the strange alien
presence of a computer that will now
take over our classrooms we're actually
being confronted with a new aspect of
ourselves
patterns at scale that we've never been
able to understand about ourselves
before this is the challenge it will
certainly change
what we know what we can learn but I
don't believe it will change the very
basic key to knowledge that Socrates was
trying to explain person to person
excitement about transmitting learning
together so I see this as a immense
opportunity to discover with our
students together
what we can do with this new technology
thank you
thank you so much Professor director
thank you very much
I'm so rich already uh have so many
thoughts and feelings uh so our next
panelist is Justin Farrell from the
sociology so Justin Farrell is a
professor of Sociology in the Yale
School of the environment he studies
American culture with a focus on social
class moral conflict epistemology and
the environment
he Blends ethnographic field work in
rural areas with large-scale
computational techniques from Network
science and machine learning so welcome
and thank you Professor Farrell
thank you so much it's great to be here
um before I I talk specifically about
the ways that that I'm responding to Ai
and my teaching I want to say a few
words about knowledge production about
about ethics and the mission of higher
education
um kind of to Echo Dr wexler's comments
as well so allow me to be a very big
picture for a moment you know I know it
might sound trite I guess maybe not but
before we start to devise
um fixes or Technical Solutions I think
we need to think harder about
the kind of culture that exists in the
modern University and how that affects
the role of I AI today
um you know all fields from on the
medical and planetary Sciences to social
sciences and Humanities they rely on
agreed upon rules and practices
educational virtues that are necessary
you know for truth seeking and they
favor uh disagreement argument uh
conflict continual openness to new
evidence and I would ask are we are we
cultivating these virtues and how can we
do better and I think this needs to be
part of the conversation for example you
know in what ways are teaching and
learning even in the most technical
fields captive to to instrumental
thinking are we limiting our students
with with surface level or or
instrumentalized visions you know of
learning and knowledge production
um these issues are are really big and
I'm I'm not naive and they're ancient as
Dr Wexler just showed and I'm not naive
to the to the Social and economic
pressures
um but all Fields you know from econ uh
to medicine to business sociology
computer science can in their own way
instill values of a liberal education
that I think will combat a culture uh
whereby you know cheating feels
necessary or even Justified
um because you know only education can
nurture a culture of true seeking of
scientific reasoning and ethical
engagement needed to to inoculate
individuals from from falling prey to
the misuse of AI
um so as AI continues to improve I think
professors and teachers need to bring a
renewed seriousness us to education
itself and poor view is a big help in
this
um so that we you know we might build
uh wisdom and character in our students
as they write papers as they do
experiments visit the archives write
computer code and just become producers
of knowledge so I hope all this can be
part of the conversation as well
um so more concretely how is AI
influencing my teaching just have two
points on this
um uh one way is is I think it's
becoming more common is is subjecting
these AI tools to critique to critique
um so I teach a field course this
semester and when when chat GPT came
online I think it was in late November
um early December I added to my syllabus
um that the the students must
investigate their research question
using chat GPT but also uh critique it
and learning through critique as we have
always done in the academy
um I identify kind of two Pathways for
critique but um there there are more
um one would obviously be to critique
the accuracy of g chat GPT essays
relative to their research question a
lot of my students have on the ground
research questions for this this class
it's very applied
um in a lot of ways
um so are the answers that it gives
accurate are they misleading unethical
um what what is missing what does it get
right or partially right the second
critique would be the eventual
commodification or current
commodification of the tool so I see
this as a as an opportunity or an
empirical question for research for my
students as we all know you know
commercial interests monetize Ai and and
cash in on these algorithms that can be
just destructive to social life so I'm
pushing students to consider how the
production of Knowledge from tools like
chat GPT might parallel similarly
developments where algorithms can profit
from from disinformation from hyperbole
or extremism or historically you know
how is this similar to or different from
previous examples uh or even pre-digital
campaigns like smoking or climate denial
where powerful commercial interests
influence the production and
dissemination of knowledge and
information to the public
secondly uh other than critiquing one
way that that I think is perhaps more
effective might be prioritizing
experiential learning and this keeping
with this course I'm teaching this
semester you know I try to get students
out of the classroom as much as possible
into the field using project-based
teaching that I think offer tools for
Discovery tools for cognitive engagement
obviously and but also social belonging
and often with that with people outside
the university who are very different
than them and so part of this course
over spring break we go to
um an area that where I do research
which is the greater Yellowstone
ecosystem and I bring my students to to
Wyoming and Montana now they have these
research projects but they're paired
with local ngos oftentimes and so they
develop a relationship and while they're
using chat GPT and for their projects
they cultivate these these virtues of
social responsibility of personal
investment in their projects and
responsibility to their on the ground
partners and so I think you know at the
present moment this type of encounter
and this type of experiences are
difficult to replicate even for AI so
I'll leave it there thank you
that's great thank you so much Professor
Farrell and so we'll hear from one more
panelist and then we have some questions
that have been coming in amazing
questions by the way people you keep
sending them in uh okay so we're gonna
hear from Professor kawaja Noreen kawaja
from the religious studies Department
professor kawaja teaches in the religion
and modernity area of religious studies
working at the intersection of
philosophy religious thought and culture
in the modern Euro Americas her work
deals with social practices of
authenticity and with the effects and
Concepts that structure our experience
of the real in fact I think this is FX
and Concepts that structure our
experience of the real okay thank you so
much professor kawaja and welcome
thank you
um so much for the inviting me to be on
this panel I've already learned a great
deal from all those who've spoken and
it's it is a very exciting opportunity
to talk about these things I think I'm
I'm in the interest of uh not repeating
some of those in the panel who I who've
already gone and who've said things that
I agree with I'll say that sort of
referring back to a few of those
comments I I think well I'll start by
saying
you know I speak not as uh in any way an
expert on artificial intelligence or
technology or the history of technology
in any way and I speak also as a teacher
at a particular kind of University that
we are all you know inhabiting it's not
the same how we might approach these
questions I think for Yale undergraduate
students for example than if we were
teaching at a larger Public School it
was a different kind of uh student
population and perhaps because of that
perhaps because of the kinds of things I
teach in the humanities the questions
about checking uh for cheating and that
sort of thing I think play a little bit
of a different role and and the way that
I think uh about these questions
um doesn't track I think alongside uh
some of those who've spoken already
doesn't track with some of the way that
the headlines are framing the issues
especially I think kind of um difficult
to talk about are two uh aspects one is
um to do I think was a broader era that
we're in you know we haven't we've been
here before is one of the themes I think
that people have been mentioning and the
that's so both in the sense of a
particular Panic about a particular kind
of tool which will introduce particular
possibilities which we can't totally map
at present and the kind of anxiety that
builds around that particular event but
then a kind of broader anxiety which I
think we're seeing in so many different
registers of social life today which you
know is kind of an ontological confusion
what what's real what's what's mine
what's yours how how the kinds of
knowledges that we practice are made
there's a lot of I think that the
conversations that we're having about AI
are maybe uh particular condensations of
a lot of the conversations that we've
been having about facts and fictions and
the Very fact that all you know AI all
these different kinds of tools that we
might describe as AI I mean people
who've worked on the kind of meaning of
that category but just insofar as we are
talking about it for ourselves as a
potential learning tool and even in
other cases of potential learning
obstacle
um I think you know kind of more
thinking about what it means to
designate it as artificial is really is
really warranted and what it means to
group a lot of these tools together as
some kind of thing that's different than
the normal way we learn because as
Laura's Professor wexler's comments kind
of indicated you know all the way back
to writing is an initial kind of
practice that we might think about as a
technology
um which which dramatically changed the
way we think and communicate and
understand ourselves and so kind of you
know breaking apart that category of
artificial and thinking through it a
little bit more granularly and where
some of these deeper conversations that
we're having you know in lots of areas
of our culture are maybe kind of feeding
this and less Focus perhaps on the
particulars this sort of one area that I
think would be really beneficial for for
students and for faculty as well
um but you know sort of the flip side of
that
um is in fact I think we do need a lot
more particular knowledge about the
specific tools but not so much you know
not only or not not limited to the way
in which the algorithms work or don't
work and not only limited to the degree
to which we can detect particular forms
of bias circulating in them but this is
a perspective that I learned from
colleagues who who
um work you know
uh in this field of History of Science
and Technology that kind of uh work that
I uh I know about from them is so
um focused on questions of how to how
technological tool tools are made who
pays for them what interests are
involved in the construction of them how
our own engagement with them benefits
the potential projects that may be in
development and you know all of those
kinds of questions are so essential to
knowing how we would be able to actually
use the tool almost like really detailed
social biographies of particular tools
we might be using that seems like
something that would be essential to
have and I mean it almost I think you
know the down the the difficulties in
doing that are both what
um some people have already mentioned
about the corporate interests and how
accessible all that information is to
the public eye and the fact that these
are often corporations who are running
them like that's not sort of a given
that we would have access to that kind
of information excuse me but but also
um uh but also I think
um
uh something that's sort of uh making
that difficult is is simply
um the pace at which these uh particular
tools are developing and so what would
that mean to do that for each uh each
you know
um artificial each example and each sort
of genre of artificial intelligence
that's going to be inundating us in the
coming you know however many years that
these that this kind of Boon is
happening and so what would that mean to
do that in each case it really does seem
to me that a kind of required course in
history of Technology history and
sociology of Technology would would need
to be would need to be something that
the university should think about so
that you know everyone would feel that
you know before we know how we even want
to talk about what creativity means or
what originality means or what cheating
would even mean in relation to a tool
like that which is not at all clear
um uh we have a sense of what it is
we're dealing with in in a really kind
of academic scholarly Rich sense and at
present that that doesn't seem to be
widely available so that's kind of
thank you so much professor kawaja and
all the panelists I feel I mean we're
going to spend 25 minutes hashing this
out further but I feel like there's so
much to think about already even if we
all just went off in a rope uh we would
get there a lot further than we've been
alone I'm gonna make one very sweeping
observation which everyone in the
audience might not need but I just feel
some pressure as the moderator to say
something like this so I we got a lot of
questions during the chat and I'm going
to bring up as many of them as I can but
I noticed that some of them refer back
to a distinction or separation that
Professor fiction always started us with
which is the space between evaluation
and learning and that sort of in the
middle of the panel we talked a lot
about the opportunities for learning and
growth and newness that this technology
opens up and how can we seize those by
by approaching it with a certain mindset
so I'd say like these are two and then
the third which I think Professor kawaja
spoke to the most directly is what she
called the ontological uncertainty of
these things happening at this
particular historical moment with our
particular social cultural economic
structures and so I'm just noticing
those three as big themes that If This
Were a classroom we're going to write a
paper I'd say pick one of these three
themes and do X and then you'd submit it
no I won't make a chat CPT joke
um so with that said I'm actually gonna
I'm gonna start with one or two
questions that came in that are a little
bit more simple and concrete
um because I think there are ways and we
didn't end up talking about them but
we'll see I I mentioned this to the
panel in advance sort of hoping even if
you don't feel like an expert that one
or at most two people will take a swing
at some of these questions and so the
first one actually came in ahead of the
panel and it may seem like it doesn't
really fit but I think it's very
important it's a it's essentially a bad
evaluation
and it's about we talked about practices
for teaching and how they might have to
change and we talked about understanding
this moment more deeply so that students
could direct their own change but one
piece of take-home writing that the
university relies on in a processing way
are application essays especially for
graduate school and so one of the
questions that came in is are there
practices or ways of that we could think
profitably about using application
essays for professional schools like
medical school and law school and we
didn't really talk about that because I
think appropriately we were thinking
about teaching from the moment of
students are with us
um but but I wonder if if anyone wants
to start with that and then I'll just
say who wants to do a follow-up and then
we'll go on to another question
Alfie can you expand on that a little
bit about oh absolutely Justin thank you
very much just what you're what what you
mean I guess so yeah yeah
how I understand the question is once
students are here we can do things with
their engagement with software like this
we um you gave some very powerful
concrete examples of ways you can have
students look at the output and do
critical reading as a way of learning
more
um we can talk to them about the
difference between what the machine can
produce and what some students in the
class can produce and help them strive
for that but when students are
submitting things to us that they've
produced at home before they're even
students
and it's hard for us to tell to what
degree they did or did not collaborate
with AI
um are there any practices or ways that
we could think about either how to feel
or read those materials or
are there different ways we could ask
questions
um of people who are applying to come to
Yale then send us a take home
essentially send us a take-home essay
answer this question uh that we've
crafted for you that's where I think the
question comes from and I think it's a
sort of a work process anxiety there's a
thing we do it takes a lot of time it's
an important part of how we get our
students here on campus and it seems
that this technology will immediately
disrupt it so I don't know if any of one
on the panel feels like you even just
want to give us
I mean like a mantras to think about if
not practice but but it seems like a
fair question to me what about the
materials that come before we even have
the students with us so that we can
engage them differently yeah Laura
you're I mean Professor well isn't this
a question of evaluation aren't you
isn't this the same question of
evaluation and
I hesitate since it's really a
a very time consuming professional
activity and I'm not doing it to make a
statement about it but the further
philosophical question is evaluating for
what what what
we we really have
now to know what the purpose of these
years that we want to spend with the
applicants would be evaluating For What
and I do think this is disruptive there
are many opportunities for disruption
um
I would hesitate to say what they are
but evaluation is one of the terms that
comes Under Pressure what for
did people need to learn to add and
subtract and multiply or was the slide
rule fine
did people need to learn to write their
own application to college or was
learning to use chat AI fine and if it
was fine what do we do with them when
they come
what is what what it what is it for that
they would be here with us we need to
talk about that
yeah that's great uh Professor Farrell I
think you're uh offered to speak back to
this too yeah I just wanted to build on
Professor works are just very quickly in
the sense of I think this is a question
of evaluation but I think it's part of a
broader emphasis or at least where we
we're moving is you know not relying on
one indicator whether it's the SA or GRE
scores but a holistic evaluation of what
the student is bringing um what the
universe can offer them as a person what
our community can provide them as they
learn with other students in community
that's really important
um as well and then obviously letters of
recommendation but hopefully those
aren't written by AI as well then I
don't know
uh Professor kawaja I see you have your
hand up I did I did have to I do confess
that that was the silent thought that
crossed my mind when we were reading all
the headlines about students using chat
GPT was what about the recommendation
side
um but uh no I also want to build on the
last two comments I think that you know
maybe this is a this is
I don't know how this point will go over
but we at the undergraduate level
obviously faculty are not at all
involved in admissions it's a complete
back black box at the PHD level which is
all that religious studies operates at
uh we don't operate in an M.A I think
it's very unlikely that
um we would have that kind of an issue
with someone submitting the kind of
extended research that you would need to
apply to a PhD program in the humanities
um but at the undergraduate level just
to take the spirit of your question on
um I think you know thinking back to
something Professor Vishnu said you know
about the use of AI one of the positive
potential uses of this kind of thing is
when there is a very distinct Norm
that's being at that that others are
being asked to follow or to meet that
because what we're looking at is a kind
of Norm machine uh like a patterned
repetition of norms that are already
flowing through the whatever they're
being fed that that can be a very
effective way and you know I I don't
know as a faculty concerned about access
and some of these other things that we
talk about today uh and equity in the
University it could be a wonderful thing
in a way if admissions essays were a
little bit more random if like
applications were a little bit more
randomized at the admissions level
um I don't think that would necessarily
be a bad thing I would rather I would
much rather be talking about what we
would use it for in a classroom or what
kind of a tool it would be than how we
would prevent people from using it
um to get into the university I that
that could be a kind of interesting hack
oh my God
yeah
so I just wanted to add to what Nori
just said uh I think uh it immediately
means that we have to diversify our
evaluation I think what also happens in
these kinds of places uh such as where
we are right now is that over time the
evaluation process has become very
stylized and start benefiting those who
have access and privilege to the kind of
or or the resources uh and I think this
in general is a bad thing in my as far
as I'm concerned and so uh perhaps we
need to just diversify evaluations and I
think we're not even saying that yeah we
have to get used to reading random uh
more I mean you know like more diverse
uh essays as opposed to all essays
having a very similar flavor and if if
one of these essays comes from outside
it feels odd and so our tendency is to
reject it or not or devaluate in some
way so I think it also helps I mean I
think at the end of the day
we as evaluators will also have to
correct our internal biases what exactly
are we responding to with these assets
this is content or is it Style
and
I I think that's that's the challenge
for us
uh and I want to acknowledge professori
that you said something like this in
your example of the student trying to
write an email who might be writing in
their second language that that it's an
evener
um
uh so we have a couple of other specific
questions that I will get to in a moment
but I want to make sure we ask one other
person to prepare for this event and
it's a student
we call it a respondent but she's not
necessarily going to respond to all of
you
um but uh her name is
and I'm going to introduce her now as
sua muigui is a senior in Yale College
majoring in political science originally
from Los Angeles she serves as a lead
writing partner at the pover center and
has been involved with the Afro-American
Cultural Center Yale's undergraduate
political journal and more and we're
going to ask her just to speak to us
just for a few moments about I mean I'll
let you say what you're where you're
speaking from
Laura thank you so much for the
thoughtful introduction
um so first and foremost it's really
been a pleasure just to hear the
perspective of so many different um
distinguished faculty and to be in
conversation with you all
so I think that the conversation that
we're having here and around the country
about chat gbt is really both a
challenge and an opportunity to think
deeper and more critically about what we
do at the University as students and as
Educators and why
and it's it's definitely true that
concerns about academic dishonesty are
warranted but ultimately we do what we
do here as students um not just to gain
credentials or to get agreed on a
transcript but really to learn how to
think to read and to solve problems
after we leave Yale and so borrowing
from what Professor Wexler said earlier
striving for the reality of learning
rather than just its appearances is
really what matters to me and I think a
lot of my peers would agree
so I think with that in mind the
critical work is to figure out how to
responsibly engage with the technology
as a tool rather than a crutch because
Tech is really an increasingly important
part of the world that we live in and
our everyday lives especially as a 21st
century student I feel they need to know
how to engage with this kind of
Technology responsibly and understand
its limits and its biases which
Professor um vishnoi spoke to earlier
some faculty at other universities have
proposed using chat gbt to represent one
side of a debate for instance and then
having students dialogue with that so I
still believe that there's room
um for us to engage with this
responsibly in the classroom
um while still maintaining the
development of those you know critical
thinking skills that technology alone
shouldn't take the place of
but all in all I'm really excited about
the changes that our engagement with
chat GPT will inspire so rethinking how
we understand learning and evaluation
creating more opportunities for
experiential learning and problem-based
learning
um so ultimately I think
staying true to our our broader mission
of learning and receiving an education
to go out into the world and solve
problems should remain at the heart of
what we do but really the the
opportunity here is is to learn how to
work with the technology understand what
it can't do and build um those critical
skills and creativity that we'll need
um and to take with us once we leave the
University
thank you so much I'm going to offer I'm
going to take one piece of what you said
and offer it as a question but the panel
please feel free to speak back in any
way to the concerns and sort of uh I'd
say hopes that sewer was expressing so
uh you you mentioned an example as to of
using chat GPT to set up a debate so
that students could sort of engage in
dialogue and and try to represent the
other side and we've heard a couple of
other examples of specific things people
might do using this tool I'll just say
four I'm about a dozen questions on my
desk in front of me and four or five of
them are could people give some more
concrete examples of ways we might
actually try to work with this tool and
not against it I understand there may be
more deep learning we have to do to make
those choices well but I wonder if
anyone on the panel is willing to just
generate a for instance you know if if a
year from now we realized oh that was
the wrong way to go well at least you
gave us somewhere to start
um yeah so on my syllabus this this
semester
um it's a requirement for students to
um
use chat GPT
check GPT to answer their research
questions and so
um they have
um a couple weeks to work with it and
then they write sort of an essay that's
responding to their research question
and then they have chat GPT as much as
it can and and just critique it in a
very basic way in the ways that I
mentioned
um I have a second assignment that I'm
going to introduce on the
commodification of these sorts of tools
and so thinking critically about those
sorts of interests as well
so very basic
so all for two examples up um one of the
things that uh we often try to train our
students to do is to differentiate the
hype about a technology from the reality
of the technology and chat CBT is a
fantastic example there where you can
look at the headlines and what is
claimed about it and then actually work
with the real system directly which is
not often something that in many cases
you're able to do and explore the
boundaries yourself and
um and especially as we're trying to
build students who are really informed
about the limits of where a technology
can go and what the likely implications
of that technology are
being able to sort of seek out and find
that own that critique on your own is a
really fantastic experience
um so we often like to pair the claims
about GPT with the experience of GPT uh
as a great learning tool
um the second thing that we often use it
for uh honestly is uh to address
questions about uh the role of the
technology and issues related to the
responsibility of authorship
um I saw just last week that science and
nature came out with two guiding rules
about how to use cheap uh chat GPT and
similar large language models in uh in
scientific papers and it was very simple
it was number one if you use them at all
uh that you must acknowledge them and
that seems to be a very easy thing for
everyone to understand but their second
rule was that chat GPT and similar
models can never be listed as an author
and the why for that I think is a really
great lesson for us and the thing that
they very explicitly said in their
announcement was that with authorship
comes a responsibility
and that none of those language models
none of those Technologies could accept
that responsibility
and so thinking about that in that way
actually lets us get at some issues
about what does it mean for these
systems to produce materials do we allow
them to be copywritten do we allow them
to have authorship should we allow them
to uh you know do are they do royalties
should we have robots that work pay
taxes
um there's a lot of questions about this
that are both at a technology level and
a policy level that are deep and Rich
and this is a great way to approach them
uh thank you very much that was very
helpful we are going to use all our
remaining eight minutes I just want to
tell you that but um we're gonna put in
the chat now a link if you feel able to
multitask I'm going to ask um you to
give us this it's it's an invitation
both to give some feedback and to raise
questions that you want the proofer
center and or other people we would ask
to help us continue to work on continue
to develop I'll mention a specific very
specific question that came into us in
advance just as an example was would the
forward Center host a session in which
faculty members who hadn't tried it
before could try chat GPT and get tips
and try another version of it and then
discuss the results and we might do that
exact thing in which case I don't know
if we'll give authorship to the person
who suggested it or not but um but we'll
certainly do things like that so I just
want to say that we'd love any other
kinds of feedback that you can give us
if you don't do it in the next seven
minutes will everyone who's registered
for this event will get as a link in a
follow-up email as well but we you know
I think it's obvious that we listen to
what everyone is out there is thinking
and saying and so it's also Anonymous by
the way you don't have to include your
contact information unless you want to
it's very explicitly in a separate
question
um and then you know most of my goal
here which has very well been achieved
is not to offer anything on my own
because you're all doing like so amazing
but I'm just going to mention something
and if people in The English Department
will want to be upset that I represented
this I apologize but there's a thing
that English 120 which is specific
course at Yale that a lot of students
take calls close reading for craft and
it puts in the foreground of teaching
writing looking at texts and thinking
about how they work and which things are
worth emulating and which where you want
to exceed or change them and I'll just
say in my own tiny little class of only
12 First Years this year I gave chat GPT
one of the homework assignments and we
looked at the example together and
talked about what what is it doing that
you thought was one of the things you
needed to do and what is it not doing
that you will even writing it for the
first time this kind of assignment you
sort of sensed needed to be done and how
could I write this assignment so that it
would ask you for more of that and less
of the first and then we had a
discussion and I'm not saying we
achieved it and like I said that may
turn out to have been naive but it's a
really specific example what wasn't even
debating with the model it was looking
at it as a piece of language constructed
and then thinking about you know what
can it do so I really just mean that as
an example
I think rather than if if one occurs to
me from this page I'll pop one more
question in there but I think what I'd
like to say is some of you didn't
respond to questions during The Question
period and is there something that you
you were thinking during the rest of the
panel or some last word you want to give
us our last question so that you know
just to give you one more shot to say
something that I'm speaking to the
panelists here
I just want to say in the materials that
Jenny Fredericks put on the poravu
website there was one person who said
that her dream was that her University
would make a week
available for faculty to kind of like go
to computer camp
um and let us learn together I I thought
that was a great idea
I'm just I'm going to add a reflection
on I'm going to say it's on what
Professor kawaja was discussing although
there was a build up I mean since she
synthesized a little bit there was a
build up to it but
um I'm thinking about how I have to take
some maybe I don't have to do anything
maybe I don't need to overreact but I'm
doing some actions in relationship with
this new technology while trying to
understand the historical moment and I
don't I don't know if you have any
advice on how to pause
um or what uh what a pattern of act and
reflect
might might look like but but this is
the thing I find myself anxious about so
I'm sort of turning to you
I mean there is no pause
um not in Yale uh and not in the world
that Yale is you know feeding and he's
fed from but
um
I mean if we were really serious about
doing it we would make one uh we would
make that week we would make that pause
we would require the class that maybe
doesn't teach the details of how a
particular technological entity that
we're dealing with is made but teaches
at a minimum students how to ask the
questions that they would need to know
and where to look for those kinds that
kind of information and us as well I
think we'd probably need a computer camp
and also a history of Tech camp for for
all of us
professors kesselotti
so I will add two things to that one
quickly is uh just that
um
uh the Dean's office actually has a
series of small bi-faculty four faculty
classes at the end of the year and uh
over the last three years we have
offered an AI for faculty or or a
natural language for faculty course so
we are actually hoping to try to address
that in in many ways
um and uh we've been also struggling to
try to find a way to address this
systemically at the undergraduate level
because we see AI tools coming out uh
that are impacting every possible area
of inquiry
um in ways that we cannot anticipate and
and and in many cases did not uh even uh
guess at in the years ahead of time
um so starting next year we're hoping to
offer an AI course for non-majors with
no programming required
um uh and uh look for more details on
that hopefully soon I'm hoping that it
gets approved the last thing I would say
is that you know we've we've talked a
lot about sort of uh what are some of
the sort of boundary cases and places
where we don't think that this
technology would be useful
um but reflecting back on the
announcements from science and nature
they acknowledge the case that there
were very good potential uses for this
technology and not only as uh Nasheed
had mentioned that you know this was a
way of leveling the field but that there
may be genuinely good places to use this
so I think one of the
challenging questions I'm left with
after this panel is what are the places
where we would want the use of this
technology in our courses
um what are the positive cases where
that would be seen as a very useful
addition and can we Define some rules
and some boundary cases to say that
beyond that is maybe not what we want to
see
so maybe we can come up with some of
those as well
that's uh I have to say I love going out
on a potential high note so thank you
for making me feel a little more
cheerful
um thank you so much to the panel I feel
really moved and daunted by your your
wisdom and care about this and thank you
for everyone who came to show that you
want to learn more about this and and
you know do Best by our students and our
culture so uh that's it for today we
will be following up with other events
and uh we're very grateful to everyone
take care
[Music]
thank you